I'm 71 I'll be 72 next month my wife is
66 this past summer and the Heat of the
summer our air conditioning went out
completely and it's going to cost us
almost
14,500 to get a new furnace and
everything can Finance it'll be almost 1
be about a 175 a month for 10 years
additionally my wife took out parent
loan for our daughter to go to college
she still owes over $100,000
on that we have bills up to our eyeballs
you have more debt than the parent Plus
loans and this 145 hpack yes what else
credit cards of course and it's about
$70,000 goodness gracious and you need
to have that hard conversation with your
daughter and say listen mom and dad are
broke and if unless you want to be taken
care of us for the next 20 years we need
to clean up our mess and you need to
clean up these student loans